hi I'm Kyle Keene and I'm Michael
Kaminski and our presentation is about a
suite of tools that we use at MIT to
teach computational thinking and
programming so I'm going to talk about a
suite of tools that we are building and
using at MIT to create curriculum like
homework assignments are you trying to
signal me oh yeah the suite of tools
that we're building and using at MIT to
make homework assignments and run live
classes all involving kind of
Mathematica and coding and mostly the
second half of the talk will be about
the data analysis that we're doing so
every assignment that we give to a
student as well as every class we
collect a lot of data about keystrokes
and code evaluations and so we are
trying to extract some useful
information like how long did students
take on this assignment what were common
syntax errors and things like that my
name is Kyle Keene and Michael Michael
Kaminski there you go and Professor
Craig Carter is our benefactor I guess
is a good word so if at any point you
zone out the important thing to remember
is you can go to code seal org and you
can download this so this is an
application that adds on to Mathematica
the ability to write homework
assignments so if you want to go
download the application then you can
build your own homework assignments
using the tools that we have created yes
there's oh wait it's projecting sorry
let's go to normal people colors yes so
there's some faces of Craig Carter and
myself and we at this point have about
10 educators who are beta testing all
the tools in their classes so it is
working and it is being used which is
exciting we have some UX designers who
are volunteering to help make things
better and a lot of students who have
found it interesting and are willing to
write content for calculus
and physics and go outside of material
science which is where we started and
then we have some educational
researchers who are helping us to define
meaningful questions that we can extract
from the data that we collected so
there's three tools let me write that
fits better three tools and they're
named so that I can keep them straight
in my mind collab Cosette and Co dat's
collab has to do with like you're inside
of a club collaborative learning
environment so we run live coding
classes Cosette it comes from at MIT
they call their homeworks problem sets
and then they shorten it to P set and we
want it to be a little bit more
collaborative coding experience so it's
a co set and code at is just fun to say
for me and it's about the data that we
collect and analyze so it's like a
Fitbit for learning so one slide one
long slide on the collab how we run live
classes the idea is fairly simple it's
I'm programming in Mathematica and my
students are programming in Mathematica
I start a collab which gives me a link
where my students can download a
notebook and then I tell my students hey
try to do this thing because I want them
to actually code inside of the classroom
so I tell them zoom in you know produce
a nice visual students do some actual
work and they make edits and I collect
data about every edit that they're
making on their code every time they do
shift-enter in Mathematica I can then
pull in all of the responses but this is
a bit of an overwhelming thing it's
fairly useful I can kind of go through
and scroll and look at what everybody's
submit it so this is helpful because I
can go make edits and talk about
people's code but the other thing that
we're adding on top of that is one more
layer which is every piece of code can
be represented as a tree and so you can
look at the distance between two trees
of code so everybody submits a piece of
code to an answer and then I as an
instructor can come and talk about a
particular
students code so I can say these people
are trying to visualize some data or
visualize a curve so a bunch of students
used lists plot some use parametric and
some use plot and I use cluster classify
to kind of find the graph communities
and figure out what students have
submitted and then I have analytics
about all of for this type of challenge
I can figure out what types of code
we're useful are these really big pieces
of code that were required or are they
short and students can figure out if
they're writing code that's kind of a
complexity that's equivalent to their
peers and we get some nice personal
analytics so it's like a Fitbit report
so you can say you know you submitted
this piece of code that was this big and
you know you're about at the level of
all the other students and not to say
that code complexity has to do with
being better or worse but it's at least
some way to do self-reflection so I was
like a animation effect the slide over
so the coset the homework system is
mildly complicated and I really like
clipart and so I've made something out
of clipart to describe it so a teacher
writes some content they make a
Mathematica notebook that's been
happening for the last 25 30 years what
you do with the system as you then click
a button and it creates a more
interactive version that the student is
going to interact with and do their work
inside of and they're going to send that
back to you so yesterday I went we had a
workshop and everybody really saw what
that process look like I will briefly
show that the system is what I mean by
authoring is there's a palette and it
comes with some templates if you want to
view an example template
for instance here is a giant notebook
that we use to teach students how to
program you can put metadata about who
has made edits to the file and then you
make a Mathematica notebook and you edit
it using this palette or using keyboard
shortcuts or using this or using file or
using format style so there's like a
thousand ways to make a notebook and
then you convert it by clicking a button
and that takes all of that work all of
that notebook and converts it into
something which is much more interactive
and involves some scaffolding so it
forces students to have tried a problem
before they get to see a solution and I
know it's very mesmerizing it's my
favorite part just sit and watch
Mathematica do a bunch of stuff it makes
multiple choice questions it adds points
that make some things optional I should
have done maybe a smaller file yeah go
get there
yeah I hope it'll get there no not
unfortunately not yet it does it does
some level of jumping it kind of goes
through three iterations of the file
it's getting close so it's shutting down
all of the sections right now I'm
packing solutions into the file with
encryption and and now it'll take one
moment to add so it has to activate the
little data a collection screen there we
go and it tells you to save it so I'm
not gonna save it all right no that was
a punchline so yeah so this is the file
that you then send to students and this
file lets them either link it to their
account their Wolfram cloud account
which lets them pull down all the data
that's collected about them I store it
with key salted hash encryption on the
Wolfram cloud or they can anonymously
give us data so that we can study how
many key presses they had and when they
were doing code and at what part of the
file or they can totally opt out so for
this I will totally opt out it tells the
student to save it I will get rid of
this pallet cuz now I'm down there yeah
all right so now I'm in student mode and
I've opened a file that the professor
has sent me and I've chosen not to
donate my data and I'm gonna go through
and there's sections that I kind of read
chapters that have lots of stuff for me
to read let's see there's probably a
problem somewhere down in here there you
go so more things these this there's
color coding if you want to change and
have a less colorful version you can do
that
problems are things or we tell them to
do work they have to go to a specific
part in the notebook and after you show
them that it's not very confusing they
give feedback so I'm a big fan of
metacognition so forcing them to reflect
on did this make sense and what part of
it did not make sense so you can tell
them to let me know this problem wasn't
asking me something that was clear or
this problem was you know too simple so
by submitting work it kind of locks
their work and graze it out and then
gives them an editable version if they
want to resubmit and by doing work they
can then view a solution so I will be
adding in the coming months the ability
to kind of not release this instantly
but to release after a certain date
right now I if they submit work they get
to see the solution we're not too
worried about catching cheaters not in
that way at least and then this gives
them a step-by-step thing where they get
to see a chunk of code and text or
whatever I want to include in my
solution and then they have to tell me
whether that step made sense or if it
was not foremost enough and they get to
view the next step and then at the very
end they have to give some reflection
and so far students have been quite
respectful of this system and they give
you know meaningful feedback we were
able to find some typos inside of the
solutions because there was points or a
bunch of students said this doesn't make
sense and we went and looked and it
didn't make sense so that was very
helpful because otherwise it's an
incredible task to try to edit one of
these giant notebooks and figure out
where errors occur and yeah so that's an
overview of kind of the workflow inside
of the notebook there's also a you know
slide view slide show view of this
notebook but I won't go into too many
more details about that so that is the
authoring
system and I abstain yes so that was
also I kind of showed the student
workflow as well I will briefly does
this countdown to the time when I need
to stop talking or the time okay
all right yeah okay that's so that's the
time when I should stop five minutes
okay all right so I'm gonna stop my I'm
gonna skip my soapbox and say you all
know if you have so this is what we want
students to give as an answer I don't
care if a student can get to the answer
to I want them to actually construct a
meaningful thoughtful using math using
code response and I don't think that
that is going to be automated anytime
soon so but I wish people luck if they
want to so next I will hand over to
Michael to talk about the data analysis
portion so all of these homework
assignments and during class we collect
every piece of code that was written and
run every keypress every notebook that's
open inside of Mathematica at any moment
how many documentation files are open so
he will talk about our attempts to
extract meaningful information there's a
long term future possible with
computer-aided grading where you say
that piece of code looks like this other
set of pieces of code that solved this
problem we are not there yet I think
right now in the short term you what you
can give as data driven insight and
reflection so I you know I spent 30
hours on this homework assignment every
year been outspent ten maybe I should
adjust my time management skills I think
that that's a very achievable insight
that we can do kind of immediately yeah
yeah so we'll start with one students
homework submission and what we can look
at and study about that particular
student
we'll talk about that all right I'm
gonna go through these in like five
minutes
you can take time we're gonna leave some
time for questions mine um so this is
like one examples of the graphs that we
might create so like just like when
you're writing an essay or you're going
through you know an English class as as
the class progresses you want to use
more and more words and expand your
vocabulary and that's kind of the goal
of an assignment that you might do in
Mathematica you'll learn more symbols
more functions and you kind of expand
like how complex your code is so this is
just keeping a running tally of kind of
like the number of symbols used by a
student over the course of an assignment
you can see it just it generally trends
upwards which is what you kind of want
to see another was some more
sophisticated ways to measure this
rather than just like the pure number of
symbols used so kind of representing
okay so kind of representing each of the
each of the evaluations as a tree you
can look at the leaves and the nodes of
the tree and use that as a gauge of code
complexity and so these are several
different measures of that and then the
average value which is the orange line
you see there or like the orange
squiggle line and just the average trend
so again you can see that in this
example the code complexity is generally
going up which is what you want to see
yeah so this is just to show like in
addition students run their own code but
they also run the code submitted by the
professors so it's important to be able
to distinguish between those because
like of all the evaluations a lot of
them are things in the actual assignment
things like they're a better examples
that the professors provide but the
actual solutions are only a small
portion of that so it's important to be
able to keep track of those and to see
which what kind of code the students are
evaluating and so since you again you
can represent the code as a tree and you
can analyze this and find the distance
between those and kind of see the way
that a student's code might evolve over
the span of an assignment over the span
of a semester you know over the span of
a course in general
yes this is just some general statistics
about like kind of the first major test
that we did with the flick following
kind of graphs so this is a pretty
simple graph it's just generally showing
when this specific student was active
apparently he did not feel like spending
five hours straight
coding non-stop in Mathematica but you
can see just kind of it's a nice little
graph to show just when someone was
active you might see some of them
bunched up towards the due date and it's
interesting just to see the kind of
distribution and just good for a
professor's he you know they assign it
to too early too late and when do people
start working on this so this is some
more examples of activity so the top one
that said just the total time worked it
shows the mean median for a class and
the highlighted bar is just kind of way
or this specific student fell in that
distribution so the like basically found
the zero to one hours of just like
actual coding so not like staring at it
doing research but like actually typing
so you can see kind of like and it's not
again it's not necessarily a measure of
like how good they were but it's just
it's good it's an interesting statistic
to see and this next one is a time
breakdown of how long people spent on
order like this one student or actually
this is the whole class spent on
different problems so that's along the
horizontal axis and the number amount of
hours worked and it's each of the bars
are split up by the sections within the
problem so again a professor might see
oh this problem took longer than I
expected for the class as a whole or you
know and be able to adjust the future
assignments accordingly
all right front anything a little bit
delightful okay this is this is
beautiful jumble of text this is what
happens when you take basically all the
code that each of the 28:29 students
wrote and you're just represented as a
word cloud and looking at this it's like
a professor looking at this might be
able to get a very like intuitive sense
like pretty quickly about what kinds of
symbols people use or like students in
general use you might not be able to you
might not want to spend the time to
individually pick out like I don't know
this one specific symbol this one
specific student use but you can kind of
see general trends people like to use pi
I like to sign a lot just pretty like
basic stuff but again it's interesting
to see and can be useful for professor
or the student in general and this is
just the same thing represented as the
class as a whole as opposed to
individual students code similarity to
talk to a little bit and another
important thing is the errors so what
people where the errors are kind of
shows where people had trouble
so representing this is like the syntax
errors as opposed to kernel errors both
there's a table and as a word clock can
kind of give you a general idea of what
people are having trouble with and
control professor what you need to focus
on and this is one specific student and
it's a time line plot of again where
they made errors so there's syntax
errors kernel errors and the different
colors represent the problem they were
working on when they had those issues
rest in peace no but
okay so one of the last things is this
is basically again word clouds of what
documentation students visited and this
is a pretty I personally think this is
pretty cool because you can see not only
what people had trouble in this area but
like what they took the steps to kind of
figure out how to use certain things you
can see people who maybe they had a lot
of errors but they didn't visit the
documentation a lot it's like maybe you
should do that and maybe you'll have
fewer errors and people who visit all
these different decorations are really
like a one-person might have gone to
visited log a lot they just couldn't
remember how do you use log yeah so you
can see for some people they might they
didn't visit documentation at all
some visited yeah one word cut per
student so again it represents the time
spent in that file the number of times
they visit it number of times they
visited yeah that's either people who
didn't go there or we're having some
issues with like the data collection for
several of them so just didn't have that
data so again it's pretty fun graph okay
I have like and this is basically the
same thing but for one student what
documentation they visited they like to
visit plot a lot log it's a good stuff
so a one and a half minutes left so one
half minutes of questions
[Applause]
yeah it'll go under passable
yeah it'll it automatically updates
itself it every time you try to use it
it checks the cloud to see if it's out
of date and it lets you know you should
update oh if you update if you reaiiy
don't know if you install a new version
you probably have to go reinstall it
yeah okay I installed the new version
and okay really remember which your your
stuff is just files yeah so they're just
notebooks yeah yeah they'll be perfectly
fine and compatible to convert again
right now it's all desktop-based know if
you have copied code that showed up in
other students solutions or in the
solutions that were given yeah yeah so
plagiarism detection is what we would
say no I there there are extremely
bright students in the class of program
before yeah no no so and and it doesn't
it never kind of accuses a student of
being a cheater but it does throw a mild
flag or we were kind of building out
code right now to throw a mild flag that
says something fishy you might want to
talk to that so so we believe in kind of
helping a human manage a classroom
better yes it's as soon as they request
their aggregated data they will get all
of the aggregated data so it's it's
constantly streaming the data to the
cloud so a student mid assignment can
pull all of their own data and analyze
it a professor mid assignment we don't
know if we'll let them but they could in
theory pull all of their data and
analyze that I think that we should wait
till the very end but maybe I won't try
to manage that thing so yeah it's it's
sitting in the cloud at any moment and
when you pull it down we're giving
notebooks that analyze it and build out
the report at any moment
you